les médicaments saisis il ya plusieurs
mois par les gendarmes étaient utilisés
en mai aux esthétiques et servait
notamment à lutter contre l'obésité en
raison de leur peu d'efficacité des
contre indications
il avait été retiré du marché français
pour satisfaire leurs clients et
encaissés au passage une confortable
marge commerciale
plusieurs dizaine de praticiens ont
sauté le pas et commander les produits
via internet
il s'agit d'une dérive et probablement
d'une infraction à certains articles du
code de déontologie
on n'a pas le droit d'utiliser des
produits qui sont dangereux ou qui n'ont
aucune action qui peuvent mettre les
patients en danger
ce sont des pharmaciens de perpignan des
marchés par une société espagnole est
inquiet de la qualité des produits qui
ont alerté les autorités sanitaires
on a fait dans les produits des
substances vénéneuses qui doivent faire
l'objet d'un étiquetage d'une
conditionnement particulier qui appelle
l'attention des professionnels de santé
des consommateurs et que bien sûr sur le
triac l'héparine et la protéine de meo
esthétique il n'y avait bien sûr aucun
de ces avertissements
le site internet a été démantelé mais
nous avons assez peu de moyens sauf des
recherches j'allais ya assez aléatoire
d'en découvrir d'autres sauf
dénonciation de la part des réseaux
disons de pharmaciens et des médecins
médecins pharmaciens ou particuliers au
total ce sont 800 témoins qui doivent
être entendus par les gendarmes sur
commission rogatoire d'un juge de
montpellier des auditions qui pourraient
déboucher en fin de semaine sur
plusieurs mises en examen